thank
here we you
see you again
thank you
please
foreign
[Music]
excellency i wish you a very warm
welcome in india
india is no stranger to you and you are
no stranger to india in your past
capacities you have visited india many
times and each time you visited
it was a very exciting time for everyone
but this time you've come for the first
time in your capacity as the president
of the european commission
and this is a very important symbol so
once again i wish you a very very warm
welcome from the bottom of my heart i
also wish to thank you uh particularly
excellency that you will be addressing
the lycena dialogue today because today
your words will be heard not just by the
intellectual and academic community in
india but around the world and the world
is waiting to know what you have to say
excellency so for this my very special
thanks and particularly because due to
covid we had to change the dates to
three times and you still
kept your commitment so uh we really
deeply appreciate that
during our last virtual summit
between india and the european union
we had great discussions of course it
would have been nicer if we could have
held that in person but we reported that
was not possible but i hope that we will
be able to have an in-person summit very
soon where we can have even deeper
discussions
when my foreign minister visited
you had good meetings with him you
had deep conversations with him and i
think that
your leadership is going to be very
important to open up uh new avenues and
take our india your relationship to new
heights and i think that with your
cooperation uh we will move very fast
forward ahead in our relationship so
once again
i wish you a very warm welcome
thank you thank you very much prime
minister and it's a pleasure to visit
india again and to see you and meet you
again so thank you very much for the
very warm welcome
and indeed this year marks the 60th and
anniversary
of the eu india relationship
and i think this relationship is today
more important
we have a lot of fun we are vibrant
democracies
we are strong supporters of the
international rules-based order
we are large economies
and
we have a lot in common but we are also
facing a challenging political landscape
and therefore i highly appreciate that
um this meeting here is possible today
and very much looking forward to the
resina dialogue indeed
we will have many topics to discuss from
security
to
the fight against climate change
but certainly we will look also
intensively
at technology digitization
and trade
and there i am very glad that
the new prime minister and i agreed
to put in place a trade and technology
council
the european union has only one trade
and technology council in place and that
is with the united states
and i think therefore it is telling
that it was so important for us
to put up a second trade of technology
council with india
and
we have
india as a technological powerhouse
it's important
because if we look at the trade among
our large economies
that